Speaker 1: All right. Let's talk a little bit
about Kerry Lake. Kerry Lake is the Republican
nominee for the Arizona gubernatorial race. Kerry
Lake is one of the most extreme candidates that
has a shot at winning in this current slate
of very deranged and delusional Republicans
that are running and will be potentially winning
some of them in just about 20 days. In a moment,
we will talk about an unlikely unless you've
been paying attention. An unlikely supporter
of Kerry Lake showing up and campaigning for
her. Her name is Tulsi Gabbard, but we'll get
to that in a little bit over the weekend. And
it's taken me time to get to this because the
shows have been so packed. Kerry Lake appeared on
CNN and Kerry Lake very clearly did not commit to
accepting the results of the election if she were
to lose. Now, Kerry Lake is slicker than some of
the other MAGA nuts where she was just able to
say, there's no way I'm going to lose. And I will,
of course, accept the results of me winning. But
this is a way to avoid committing to accepting
the results if she loses. And we know she's not
going to accept the results if she loses. How do
we know? Well, even in the Republican primary,
which was it took a while to get a final result
during the counting period, including when
she fell behind, she started crying voter
fraud. So we know from what happened a couple
of months ago that she's not going to accept
the results anyway. Let's get to the clip. Here
is Dana Bash trying to pin her down on this.
Speaker 5: I question is, will you accept
the results of your election in November?
I'm going to win the election and I will accept
that result. If you lose, will you accept that
that result because the people will never. The
people of Arizona will never support and
vote for a coward like Katie Hobbs who
won't show up on a debate stage. She's sick.
Speaker 1: I you know, I said this regarding
the White House press secretary Kayleigh MCENANY
is comments in the summer of 2020, which was,
you know, the president can't decide, shouldn't
be able to decide whether to accept the results
solely on the basis of whether they have won or
they have lost. But that's exactly what Trump and
Kayleigh MCENANY were setting Trump up to do in
that summer of 2020. It was I will accept it if
I win, but it's going to be fraud if I lose. And
Trump never said it in that language. Caylee never
said it in that language. But they made it clear
there is all these ways Democrats are going to
try to steal it. And if indeed we lose by a little
bit, it will be because Democrats have stolen it.
But obviously, if we win, if we are reelected by
the will of the people, which of course we will
be, then we will accept that. And at the time
I said, this isn't how democracy is supposed to
work and it is happening again. Republicans will
accept election results when they win, and if they
don't win, they will say that it was fraudulent
or it was stolen or it was rigged or whatever
the case may be. That is actual authoritarian
fascism. That's not actually democracy. There
was more of this very delusional interview.
I'll play a little bit of it for you here.
Speaker 5: If leaders like you and President
Trump are saying that the election was stolen.
Are you participating, contributing, even causing
the idea of people thinking that the election is
not safe and secure? No. We are going to make sure
our elections are safe and secure for Democrats,
independents and Republicans alike. We want
to know that our legal vote counted. We want
to know the winner on election night. We don't
want to be counting for ten days, but we want
everyone to know. But you can count it. Don't
you want your votes counted in real time? Don't
you want your votes to be counted no matter how
long it takes in 2022 in November? Dana, Dana,
I've been on the campaign trail for 503 days. I
talked to moms and dads who are losing children
because of fentanyl poisoning. I talked to
retirees who can't afford gas and food. I
talked to parents whose children are getting out
of high school and can't read. We have serious
problems. We have totally agree on it. I totally
agree. Which is why the election denial has me
on here. Dana, you want to have me on here and
talk 2020 election and you're like, I would never
bring this up, ever had you not been bringing
this up consistently on the campaign trail.
Speaker 1: Let's Carry Lake is truly horrible.
Speaker 5: Forward then will you accept
the results of the election?
Speaker 1: Okay, so now we get
into the part that we have already seen. This
is a critical election in Arizona. I can't
tell you how much of a joke the United
States will be seen as. I mean, listen.
Trump won in 2016, so that being seen as a joke
would not be new. But this woman is a cartoon,
and sadly, she's winning right now.
The real Clear Politics average for
the Arizona gubernatorial race between Cory Lake
and Katie Hobbs has Kerry Lake 1.6 points ahead,
1.6 points ahead with a new DWI Trafalgar Poll
having her plus three. That being said, there's a
poll from four days prior which has Katie Hobbs up
one. But the message here is and we've got a great
TikTok video actually about this. Kerry Lake could
win. And turn Arizona into truly a laughing stock
of the United States globally, where people are
emailing me saying, what the hell is wrong with
these people, particularly Kari Lake? They may
do it, they may do it. And so I hope that all
of our Arizona voters are planning to vote.
This is one we'll be watching very closely.